Je m'appelle Rich Baraniuk.
Et je voudrais parler un peu aujourd'hui de quelques idées
qui je pense ont une formidable résonance
avec tout ce dont on a parlé ces deux derniers jours.
En fait, tant de différents points de résonance
que ça va être difficile de les aborder tous, mais je vais essayer de faire de mon mieux.
Quelqu'un se souvient-il de ces choses-là?
(Rires)
Bon, donc ce sont des disques 33 tours vinyles et on les a remplacé.
Ils ont été balayés au cours des deux dernières décennies
par ces types de technologies de numérisation qui aplatissent le monde.
Et je pense que le meilleur témoignage
c'était quand Thomas jouait la musique tandis que nous entrions dans la salle aujourd'hui.
Ce qui s'est passé dans le monde de la musique, c'est qu'il y a une culture
ou un écosystème qui a été créé
qui, si vous prenez quelques mots d'Apple,
le slogan que nous créons, extraiyons, mélangeons et gravons.
Ce que je veux dire par là c'est que n'importe qui dans le monde est libre
et est autorisé à créer une musique nouvelle et des idées musicales.
N'importe qui dans le monde est autorisé à extraire ou à copier des idées musicales,
à les utiliser de façon novatrice.
N'importe qui est autorisé à les mélanger par différents moyens,
établir des liens entre des idées musicales
et les gens peuvent les graver ou créer des produits finaux et recommencer.
Et cela a créé, comme je l'ai dit,
une communauté vivante qui est faite
de gens qui travaillent en permanence à connecter des idées musicales,
à innover et à mettre en permanence à jour.
La chanson à succès d'aujourd'hui n'est pas celle de l'an dernier.
Mais, je ne suis pas ici pour parler de la musique d'aujourd'hui.
Je suis ici pour parler de livres.
En particulier, les manuels et le type de matériel éducatif
que nous utilisons tous les jours à l'école.
Quelqu'un a t-il ici jamais été à l'école?
(Rires)
Bon, Y a-t-il quelqu'un qui se rende compte qu'il y a une crise dans nos écoles,
partout dans le monde?
Je l'espère, je ne vais pas passer trop de temps là-dessus,
mais je veux parler de quelques-unes des déconnections
qui apparaissent quand un auteur publie un livre
qui, en fait, le processus de publication -
simplement du fait que c'est compliqué,
il est lourd, les livres sont chers -
crée une sorte de mur entre les auteurs de livres
et les utilisateurs finaux de livres,
qu'ils soient enseignants, étudiants ou simplement les lecteurs en général.
Et c'est encore plus vrai si vous parlez une langue
autre que l'une des principales langues du monde, et surtout l'anglais.
Et j'appellerai ces gens Les exilés
parce qu'ils sont vraiment à l'écart du processus
d'être en mesure de partager leurs connaissances avec le monde.
Et donc je veux parler aujourd'hui d'essayer de prendre ces idées,
que nous avons vu dans la culture musicale
et d'essayer de les utiliser pour réinventer la façon
d'écrire des livres, de les utiliser et à enseigner avec.
Donc, c'est ce dont je voudrais parler
et vraiment, comment passer d'où nous sommes maintenant au point où nous devons aller?
Ainsi, la première chose que je voudrais vous faire, c'est une petite expérience de réflexion.
Alors, imaginez prendre tous les livres du monde.
Imaginez des livres
et imaginez simplement arracher les pages.
Alors, vous libérez ces pages et imaginez les numériser,
et vous les stockez dans un vaste dépôt mondial interconnecté.
Pensez-y comme un iTunes énorme, pour un contenu de livres.
Et puis que le matériel et d'imaginer ce qui en fait l'ensemble ouvert,
de sorte que les gens peuvent le modifier, jouer avec, l'améliorer.
Imaginez faire que ce soit gratuit, de sorte que n'importe qui dans le monde peut avoir accès
à l'ensemble de ces connaissances et imaginez utiliser la technologie de l'information
pour mettre à jour ce contenu, l'améliorer, jouer avec,
sur une échelle de temps de l'ordre de secondes plutôt que d'années.
Au lieu d'éditions qui paraissent tous les deux ans,
d'un livre, imaginez qu'il sorte toutes les 25 secondes.
Alors, imaginez qu'on puisse le faire
et imaginez que nous puissions impliquer les gens dans ce projet.
Afin que nous puissions vraiment construire un écosystème avec non seulement les auteurs,
mais toutes les personnes qui pourraient être ou voudraient être les auteurs
dans toutes les langues du monde,
et je pense que si vous pouviez faire cela, ça s'appellerait,
je vais tout simplement en parler comme un écosystème de la connaissance.
Donc, vraiment, c'est le rêve
et dans un sens ce que vous pouvez en penser
nous essayons de permettre à n'importe qui dans le monde,
j'insiste, n'importe qui dans le monde
d'être don propre DJ de l'éducation.
en créant du matériel éducatif, en le partager avec le monde,
en innovant en permanence avec. Donc, c'est le rêve.
En fait, ce rêve est effectivement en train de devenir réalité.
Au cours des six dernières années et demie,
nous avons travaillé très dur à Rice University
sur un projet intitulé Connexions,
et donc ce que je voudrais faire dans la suite de ma conférence
c'est simplement de vous parler un peu de ce que les gens font
avec Connexions, ce que vous pouvez considérer comme le contrepoint
de la conférence de Nicholas Negroponte d'hier,
où ils travaillent sur le matériel
pour apporter l'éducation au monde.
Nous travaillons sur les outils open-source et le contenu, d'accord?
Donc, voilà une sorte de mise en perspective.
Bien, créer, donc qui sont quelques-unes des personnes qui utilisent ce genre d'outils?
Eh bien, d'abord,
il y a une communauté de professeurs de génie, de Cambridge à Kyoto,
qui développent un contenu d'ingénierie en génie électrique
pour développer ce que vous pouvez considérer comme un méga super manuel,
qui couvre tout le domaine de l'ingénierie électrique
et non seulement cela, il peut être personnalisé
pour une utilisation dans chacune de leurs propres institutions.
Si des gens comme Kitty Jones - oui, une exilée -
professeur de musique privé et mère de famille de Champagne, dans l'Illinois,
qui a voulu partager son contenu musical fantastique avec le monde,
sur la façon d'apprendre aux enfants à jouer de la musique.
Son matériel est maintenant utilisé plus de 600.000 fois par mois.
Énorme, énorme utilisation.
En fait, beaucoup de cette utilisation vient des Etats-Unis, des écoles primaire et secondaire
car toute personne impliquée dans une restriction budgétaire à l'école,
la première chose qu'on supprime c'est la musique
et ceci indique donc simplement la soif énorme
pour ce type de contenu libre et gratuit.
Beaucoup d'enseignants utilisent ce genre de choses. Bon, qu'en est-il des droits?
Qu'en est-il de copier, de réutiliser?
Une équipe de bénévoles à l'Université du Texas-El Paso,
des étudiants des cycles supérieurs qui traduisent les idées de ce super manuel d'ingénierie
et en moins d'une semaine, c'est devenu un de nos outils les plus populaires
largement utilisé dans toute l'Amérique latine et en particulier au Mexique,
en raison de sa nature ouverte et extensible.
Des gens, des bénévoles et même des entreprises
qui traduisent des ressources pédagogiques vers des langues asiatiques
telles que le chinois, le japonais et le thaïlandais,
pour diffuser les connaissances encore plus loin.
Bon, et les gens qui recomposent? Qu'est-ce que signifie recomposer?
Recomposer signifie la construction de cours sur mesure,
signifie la construction de livres personnalisés.
Des sociétés comme National Instruments,
qui insèrent des simulations interactives très puissantes dans les ressources,
afin que nous puissions aller au-delà de notre genre habituel de manuels scolaires
vers une expérience dans laquelle vous pouvez interagir
jouer et apprendre en même temps
avec tous les matériels pédagogiques.
Nous avons travaillé avec Enseignants sans Frontières
qui sont très intéressés par la recomposition de nos matériaux.
Ils vont utiliser Connexions comme plate-forme
pour développer et fournir du matériel pédagogique
pour former des professeurs
dans 84 pays dans le monde entier.
TWB (Enseignants sans Frontières) forme actuellement 20.000 enseignants en Irak avec le soutien de l'USAID
et pour eux, cette idée d'être en mesure de remixer
et de personnaliser au contexte local est extrêmement importante,
parce que fournir du contenu gratuit aux gens
a en fait été assimilé par les personnes dans le monde en développement
à une sorte d'impérialisme culturel,
et si vous ne permettez pas aux gens
de pouvoir re-contextualiser le matériel pédagogique,
de le traduire dans leur propre langue et se l'approprier,
ça ne va pas.
D'autres organisations aec qui nous avons travaillé, UC Merced,
les gens connaissent UC Merced.
Il s'agit d'une nouvelle université en Californie, dans la vallée centrale,
qui travaille en étroite collaboration avec les universités communautaires.
Ils élaborent en fait 'une grande partie de leur programme de sciences et génie
pour le diffuser largement dans le monde entier dans notre système
et ils cherchent également à développer l'ensemble de leurs outils logiciels complètement open-source.
Nous avons travaillé avec AMD qui a un projet appelé 50 d'ici 15,
qui cherche à apporter la connectivité Internet
à 50 pour cent de la population mondiale d'ici à 2015.
Nous allons leur fournir du contenu
dans toute une gamme de langues différentes,
et nous travaillons aussi avec un certain nombre d'autres organisations.
En particulier, un tas de projets
qui sont financés par la Fondation Hewlett,
qui a joué un rôle de véritable leadership dans ce domaine de contenus ouverts.
OK, graver, je pense que c'est tout à fait intéressant.
Graver est l'idée d'essayer de créer l'instanciation physique d'une de ces cours
et je pense que beaucoup d'entre vous ont reçu,
je pense que tous vous avez reçu l'un de ces livres de musique dans votre sac cadeau.
Un petit cadeau pour vous.
Juste pour vous en parler rapidement, il s'agit d'un manuel d'ingénierie.
Environ 300 pages, cartonné.
Devinez combien ça coûte?
Combien cela coûterait-il dans une librairie?
Public : 65 dollars.
Richard Baraniuk: Cela coûte 22 dollars à l'étudiant.
Pourquoi ça coûte 22 dollars?
Parce qu'il est publié à la demande
et il est développé à partir de ce dépôt de matériel libre.
Si ce livre devait être publié par un éditeur ordinaire,
il en coûterait au moins 122 dollars.
Bien, donc ce que nous voyons c'est que le processus
de gravure ou de publication passe de l'auteur unique habituel
vers du matériel produit par une communauté d'auteurs
qui est modulaire, qui est adapté à chaque classe
et publié à la demande à très peu de frais,
soit en passant par Amazon,
ou publié directement par un imprimeur spécialisé, comme Coop.
Et je pense que c'est un domaine extrêmement intéressant
parce qu'il y a un secteur énorme sous cette longue traîne dans l'édition.
Nous ne parlons pas de la courbe côté Harry Potter, complètement à gauche.
Nous parlons de livres sur les équations dérivées partielles hyper géométrique.
Des livres qui pourraient vendre 100 exemplaires par an, 1.000 exemplaires par an.
Il y a d'énormes recettes sur la durée,
sous cette longue traîne pour soutenir les projets en cours comme le nôtre,
mais aussi pour soutenir cette émergence de nouveaux éditeurs à la demande,
comme Coop qui a produit ces deux livres,
et je pense que l'une des choses que vous devriez reternir de cette conférence,
c'est que l'intermédiaire va inévitablement disparaître
La désintermédiation. c'est ce qui va arriver dans le secteur de l'édition
et elle va atteindre un crescendo au cours des prochaines années,
et je pense que c'est pour notre bien réellement, et pour le bien de la planète.
Bon, alors quelles sont les facilitateurs?
Qu'est-ce qui permet que tout ça arrive?
Il y a des tonnes de technologie,
et la seule technologie dont je veux vraiment parler est XML.
Combien de gens connaissent XML?
Oh, génial, C'est donc l'avenir de l'Internet.
C'est la représentation sémantique de commentaire, de contenu,
et vous pouvez vraiment concevoir XML dans ce cas,
comme l'emballage que nous mettons autour de ces pages.
Rappelez-vous, nous avons pris le livre, déchiré les pages?
Eh bien, ce que le XML va faire, c'est en fait -
il va transformer ces pages en blocs Lego.
XML c'est les bosses sur le Lego
qui nous permettent ainsi de combiner le contenu d'un million de façons différentes
et il nous fournit un cadre pour partager le contenu.
Ainsi, il vous permet de prendre cet écosystème,
dans son état primordial, de tout ce contenu,
toutes les pages que vous avez arraché des livres
et de créer des machines d'apprentissage très sophistiquées , vous voyez?
Des livres, des cours, des notes de cours.
Il vous donne la possibilité de personnaliser l'apprentissage
pour chaque étudiant,
de sorte que chaque étudiant peut avoir un livre ou un cours
adapté à leur mode d'apprentissage, leur contexte,
leur langue et les choses qui les intéressent.
Il vous permet de réutiliser les mêmes matériels de multiples façons,
surprenantes et nouvelles .
Il vous permet de relier des idées
en indiquant comment les champs sont en relation les uns aux autres,
et je vais vous raconter mon histoire personnelle.
Nous avons eu cette idée, il y a six ans et demi
parce que j'enseigne les trucs ici dans la zone rouge.
Et mon travail de jour, comme Chris a dit, je suis professeur de génie électrique.
J'enseigne le traitement du signal
et mon défi était de montrer que ces mathématiques -
houla, environ la moitié d'entre vous se sont déjà endormi rien qu'en regardant l'équation -
(Rires)
mais ces mathématiques en apparence ardues sont en fait le coeur
de ce site web extrêmement puissant qui relie la technologie -
qui relie des applications vraiment cool comme des synthétiseurs de musique
à d'énormes opportunités économiques,
mais aussi régi par la propriété intellectuelle.
Et ce que j'ai réalisé c'est qu'il n'y avait aucun moyen pour moi
en tant qu'ingénieur, de pouvoir écrire ce livre qui ferait passer tout ça.
Nous avions besoin d'une communauté pour le faire
et nous avions besoin de nouveaux outils pour être en mesure de relier ces idées,
et je pense que vraiment, dans un sens, ce que nous essayons de faire
est de réaliser le rêve de Minsky,
où l'on peut imaginer tous les livres dans une bibliothèque
effectivement commencer à parler les uns aux autres,
et tous les enseignants,
ceux qui enseigne, vous savez.
L'enseignement, c'est vraiment les interconnexions entre les idées.
Bon, revenons aux mathématiques, imaginez que cela est possible.
Que chaque équation que vous cliquez dans l'un de vos nouveaux manuels électroniques
est quelque chose que vous allez être en mesure d'explorer et d'expérimenter.
Alors imaginez le manuel d'algèbre de votre enfant, en cinquième.
Vous pouvez cliquer sur chaque équation
et mettre en place un petit outil pour pouvoir expérimenter ,
bricoler, comprendre cette équation
parce que nous ne comprenons pas vraiment tant que nous ne faisons pas.
Le même type de marqueur, comme MathML, pour la chimie.
Imaginez des manuels de chimie qui comprennent réellement
la structure de la formation des molécules.
Imaginez la musique XML
qui permet en fait, de vous plonger dans la structure sémantique de la musique,
de jouer avec , de la comprendre.
Il n'est pas étonnant que tout le monde s'y mette, non?
Même les rois mages.
(Rires)
Bon, le deuxième grand catalyseur, et c'est là que j'ai dit un gros mensonge.
le deuxième grand catalyseur est la propriété intellectuelle,
car en fait je suis venu ici
et j'ai parlé de la grandeur de la culture musicale.
Nous pouvons partager et ripper, mixer et graver, mais en fait c'est complètement illégal.
Et nous serions accusés de piratage si on faisait ça,
parce que cette musique est devenue propriétaire.
C'est maintenant la propriété, en grande partie, des grandes industries.
Donc, vraiment, l'essentiel ici est qu'on ne peut pas laisser cela se produire.
Nous ne pouvons pas laisser ce Napster se produire ici
Donc, ce que nous devons faire c'est bien faire les choses dès le début
et ce que nous devons faire
c'est trouver un cadre de propriété intellectuelle qui permet de partager en toute sécurité,
et qui soit facilement compréhensible,
et on s'inspire ici du logiciel open-source,
comme Linux et la GPL.
Et les idées, les licences Creative Commons.
Combien de personnes ont entendu parler de Creative Commons?
Si ce n'est pas le cas, vous devez vous informer là-dessus. Creativecommons.org.
Au bas de chaque matériel dans Connexions
et dans beaucoup d'autres projets, vous trouvez leur logo.
Cliquer sur ce logo vous amène à un document absolument sans fioritures,
lisible pour un humain,
un acte qui vous dit exactement ce que vous pouvez faire avec ce contenu.
En fait, vous êtes libre de le partager, de faire toutes ces choses,
de le copier, de le modifier, même d'en faire une utilisation commerciale
tant que vous l' attribuez à l'auteur.
Parce que dans l'édition universitaire
et une grande partie de l'édition scolaire,
il s'agit vraiment de partage des connaissances, c'est pour ça, et d'avoir de l'impact,
c'est pourquoi les gens écrivent, pas nécessairement pour faire du fric.
Nous ne parlons pas de Harry Potter,
Nous sommes à la fin de la longue traîne ici.
Derrière ça il y a le code juridique,
donc, si vous voulez le construire très attentivement,
et Creative Commons se déploie.
Plus de 43 millions de choses là-bas,
sous licence avec une licence Creative Commons.
Pas seulement du texte, mais de la musique, des images, des vidéos
et il y a en fait un intérêt énorme
du nombre de personnes qui déposent vraiment les licences pour de la musique
pour la rendre gratuite pour les gens qui font du ré-échantillonnage,
rip, mixage, gravure et partage.
Donc, je voudrais conclure avec ces quelques derniers points.
Donc, nous avons construit cette idée d'un bien commun. Les gens l'utilisent.
Nous recevons plus de 500.000 visiteurs uniques par mois, rien que sur notre site particulier.
Le matériel pédagogique libre du MIT , qui est un autre grand site de contenu libre,
obtient un nombre similaire de visites, mais comment pouvons-nous protéger cela?
Comment le protegerons-nous dans le future
et la première chose que les gens ont sans doute en tête est le contrôle de qualité.
Parce que nous disons que tout le monde peut contribuer
à ce fond commun. Tout le monde peut contribuer à tout,
et ça pourrait être un problème.
Donc, il n'a pas fallu longtemps,
jusqu'à ce que des gens commencent à contribuer par exemple avec des ressources sur la lingerie,
qui en fait est un très bon module.
Le seul problème est qu'il est plagié,
d'une importante magazine feminin français
et quand vous allez à la page du cours supposé,
elle pointe vers un site de vente de lingerie.
Donc, c'est un peu un problème,
et nous avons clairement besoin d'une idée de contrôle de la qualité
et c'est vraiment là que l'idée de révision et d'évaluation par les pairs entre en jeu.
Bon, vous arrivez à TED. Pourquoi venez-vous à TED?
Parce que Chris et son équipe se sont assurés
que les choses sont de très, très haute qualité,
et nous devons donc être en mesure de faire la même chose.
Et nous devons être en mesure de concevoir des structures
et ce que nous faisons c'est convevoir des logiciels sociaux
pour permettre à tout le monde de construire son propre processus de révision par les pairs
et nous appelons ces choses des lentilles
et au fond ce qu'ils permettent c'est que n'importe qui
puisse mettre au point son propre processus de révision par les pairs,
afin qu'ils puissent se concentrer sur le contenu du référentiel
qu'ils pensent vraiment important
et vous pouvez penser à TED comme une lentille potentielle.
Donc, je voudrais simplement terminer en disant,
vous pouvez vraiment considérer cela comme un appel à l'action.
Connexions et le contenu libre c'est le partage des connaissances.
Vous tous ici êtes extrêmement empreints
d'énormes quantités de connaissances
et ce que je voudrais faire, c'est d'inviter chacun d'entre vous
à contribuer à ce projet et d'autres projets de ce type,
parce que je crois qu'ensemble nous pouvons vraiment changer le paysage
de l'éducation et de l'édition scolaire.
Alors, Merci beaucoup.